la russie a fermé le robinet de gaz en
pologne en bulgarie le géant gazprom sur
ordre de moscou a annoncé suspendre ses
livraisons vers les deux pays la pologne
s'est préparé à diversifier ses
importations de gaz même avant
l'inauguration du gazoduc qui nous
fournira un gaz norvégien nous serons
capables de protéger notre économie face
à cette décision radicale de la russie
si quelqu'un souhaite s'ingérer dans les
événements actuels riches à un tiers en
l'occurrence
alors il doit savoir que cela
constituera une menace géopolitique pour
nous il doit savoir qu'il y aura une
réponse aux précisément une frappe de
réponse rapide mais il semblerait
nakic eu
raison
quarante mille salariés les licenciés
c'est difficile continuez à les payer
sans avoir de perspective raisonnable de
retour à la normale c'est tout aussi
difficile en italie le sol s'effondre
les russes à fès dans plusieurs grandes
villes annappes à rome une roche friable
serait en cause et le rythme de ces de
ces effondrements s'accélère ces
dernières années sans que les
scientifiques comprennent pourquoi
emmanuel ma pensée c'est vrai qu'on
prend un risque en ouverture du paraphe
est regardé comme trois millions et demi
de français j'ai voté blanc
nicolas sarkozy avait demandé de voter à
emmanuel macron
jean castex à l'ailé droite il a mené
des politiques les plus sociales des
dernières décennies
cette hausse fait un homme de coeur et
vous n'allez pas me refaire la campagne
dont il avait perdu
vous foncer dans le mur depuis des mois
les républicains on peut pas être les
républicains et reconquête on ne peut
pas être les les républicains et et
horizons on est les républicains un
groupe indépendant la double
appartenance n'existe pas votre
arrogance est tellement maintenant
rallier les quarts et 4 vient de gâcher
vous divertir je vais vous dire que vous
répond madame est ce que je peux vous
répondre allez-y quand vous avez un
ralliement et que vous le brandy c'est
comme un trophée vous n'avez pas idée de
ce que ça donne en terme d'image de
comptes de manque de conviction dans
l'opinion publique tout ce que les gens
détestent eric zemmour milite toujours
pour l'union des droites aux élections
législatives voici le message du
président de reconquête sur twitter nous
ne présenterons pas de candidat face à
marine le pen eric ciotti et nicolas
dupont aignan en marche ne s'est agrégée
que avec des gens qui sont partis dès le
départ avec emmanuel macron cela à cela
vaut mon respect et les autres ce sont
des traîtres qui sont venues de la
droite et de la gauche les gens ont
horreur de ça après les communistes et
les écologistes
ce matin c'est au tour du parti
socialiste de tenter un rapprochement
avec les ans où nous avons eu une
discussion constructive qui nous a
permis d'avancer sur un certain nombre
de points permettant de voir et de
considérer qu'il n'y avait pas entre
nous deux points de blocage
insurmontable j'ai pas le sentiment que
la france soumise aujourd'hui disque
livré des armes à l'ukraine est une
bêtise cité elle continue le dire oui et
bien je trouve que ça effectivement cinq
points des mets du coup vous n'avez pas
parler pour l'instant on attend
maintenant de la part du parti
socialiste d une déclaration publique
qui permettent d'acter ces points de
convergence sur le fond on verra si dans
les prochains jours elle aura lieu
embargo sur le gaz et le pétrole russe
ce sont des décisions qui vont qui
peuvent être prises aussi par
l'assemblée nationale les insoumis 10 ce
serait une aberration vous vous dites
est lancée il faut le faire tout de
suite là encore c'est un désaccord
[Musique]
la poser la question à manuel bompard
qui du côté des insoumis pas plus tard
que lundi matin qui nous a dit sur le
nucléaire ce ne sera pas dans l'accord
ce attendait ce sera soumis à un
référendum des français
on est au courant non les mots ont perdu
leur sens dans l'époque nous traversons
les gens emploie le mot génial pour rien
pour des repas pour des mobylettes mais
tu étais un génie